the context of this is like all these
different pizza places from what
tri-state area yeah yeah for the most
part you've done your one bite review
yeah that's right and I know most of the
pizzerias I've met them I'm friends with
them I've scored them I've helped a lot
of them so these are the superstars yeah
fairly close knit they're gonna come and
they're gonna go to this stadium and
they're going to recreate the kitchens
it was the thing it was the best pizza
you can have so they're all that this is
a big thing to put together this is not
hey we're gonna throw some pizzas in
boxes and then deliver them to a park
and then everybody grabs a slice this is
the [__] you looked at it and it
looked like mini storefronts basically
we let them pick their ovens we went out
and so there were all sorts of different
types of ovens it was a big production
to put together
um and then probably like a week week
and a half it started this dude Kenji
allp Lopez who I never heard of
celebrity chef okay um like a million
million dollars YouTube channel
um 600 Instagram and he started publicly
tagging the pizza places and being like
how the [__] can you support Dave
Portnoy and all the hit pieces that have
been written quoting them including like
I'm a union Buster all this stuff uh and
just going crazy he was also friends
with the Washington Post so where's his
animosity for you coming from this is a
crazy political human so I didn't
realize so his identity is politics
which I didn't realize he he actually
during covid he had to take this down
and apologize that's always the same he
basically said if you support Trump it's
no different than being a Nazi or
wearing a white Hood like in the KKK if
you come to my restaurant he won't serve
you yeah so that that's the vibe and I
have clearly been perceived as well Dave
interviewed Trump all that [__] so that
was where it was coming from in every
hit piece so
he was going crazy posting it posting
tagging shaming the pizza places and
he's getting rewarded from his followers
and he gets to feel like a hero he's
everybody he doesn't allow comments as
an echo chamber of just his world yes
um and the there's two authors of the
Washington Post article Emily Hill and
then Tom Karma man I guess who guess who
he's a super fan of Kenji all Lopez oh
well well well what a shock like yeah he
had this guy the other author had one
picture on his Instagram that wasn't
himself it was Kenji that's the only one
so shocking how that works
um and what was this on Thursday before
the festival or maybe once I forget but
we get an email from a sponsor sent to
me being like heads up the Washington
Post is writing an article about the
festival and they basically sent an
email hey we want to talk to you about
supporting the pizza Fest and being
involved with Dave who is a racist here
comes the word I can pronounce
made her quite likable she could have
somebody who is as unfamiliar with that
term
I'll never be able to pronounce it
misogynist misogynist misogynist
um you're losing it already and
basically sent the email to the average
I was being like please defend yourself
putting them in a box yeah it was crazy
what the [__] is a sponsor supposed to
say how could you support a pizza Fest
that is run by a misogynist yeah right
and a racist but they're also sending it
to a bunch of old school Italians
[Laughter]
was this was a major like
Blue Chip sponsor the one that spent so
these are the sponsors not the actual
kids yes but they did it to everybody
yeah so uh I and she put her number to
call back on so that was sent to me and
like you know what I'm just gonna call
this woman and see what the deal is
um watching her melt so I called her and
the call went as bad really for her as
it possibly could because right off the
bat
I'm like why are you sending this email
saying I'm the m word and because I
can't pronounce it and racist and she's
like I didn't do that like I haven't
done that yeah well let me read you the
email I write her the emails like oh I
just did that once I'm like that's weird
you just said you didn't do it and I
just read it to you and then the
conversation continued I'm like do you
know anything about me she's like no I'm
like well then how could you send this
email if you don't know anything about
me she's like well we're going to talk
to you later which they weren't
um and continued on and then the
journalistic tactic that was she she
said we only send something negative to
try to get people to engage it's a
journalistic tactic I'm like well that's
[__] social so it's it's almost as if
she's admitting that her form of
Journalism is to manipulate the person
she's interviewing to satisfy the angle
of the article totally which is no
Integrity in the journalism it's I'm
gonna prompt you so that you react to
this prompt so I can take that one sound
bite and be like yes we are aware that
he does this stuff and we really
questioned it but maybe for the greater
good we thought it was okay so now she's
confirming who it is but on the phone I
couldn't believe she said it me neither
she was just like oh yeah we fake
stories yeah that's that's the kind of
way that I debate is most journalism I
wonder they have to compete with YouTube
now I wonder if journalists are like the
only way that they can get people to
watch their video reports or their even
read their essays is that if they
compete with the clickbait of YouTube
it's all clickbait and then she also did
something which there's been almost my
biggest complaint there's so many hit
pieces they're all the same [__] they
the hippies reads the other hippies and
prints it as though it is fact and how
would anybody actually know if it's true
or not because they haven't done the
research to dig into it's like I've
offered to everybody sit down
I'm an open book put a camera I will go
through every point in an open mind at
the end it's gonna be like this is
garbage how has this ever been Prince
about him but she said I'll sit down
with you at 10 A.M then she picked the
time she's like 10 a.m I agreed to it
knowing the piece was already written
and then they canceled that and they're
like we want to move it to 5 p.m well
the article has to come out in like five
minutes so so why would I agree to that
yeah I didn't understand the angle right
there but I guess it's they wanted to
call with you after the article would
already be printed so and you were
trying to beat the Article yes so that
you could at least get a fair shake and
by the way journalists that's the thing
they don't want the fair Shake because
it puts them at risk if you're printing
something you can always plead ignorance
next I didn't know that I didn't know
that you can't say that if you've spoken
with me and I've basically given you
facts and proof and evidence that
contradicts what you're right okay
that's why they don't want the the
subject